the war in ukraine was high on the
agenda as german chancellor olaf schultz
met with japanese prime minister fumio
kishida in tokyo today this is schultz's
first trip to asia as chancellor and he
chose japan as the regional starting
point his recent predecessors have all
gone to china first so the move is a
departure from previous protocol and
considered to possibly be a signal uh to
possibly signal a shift in focus
after decades of pacifism germany
recently shifted policy by authorizing
sales of heavy weaponry to ukraine and
by increasing its defense budget now
japan is considering taking similar
steps
a promotional video showing japan's navy
at work
a thinly veiled advertisement for the
japanese government's rearmament plans
the sea may look peaceful the narrator
says but the world is changing
japan also feeling the effects of
russia's military aggression
shigeru ishiba is a former minister for
defence and one of the most prominent
voices calling for japan to re-arm
it's true the war in ukraine has woken
up the japanese people
they're thinking about how to better
protect their country
the alliance between chinese president
xi jinping and vladimir putin has
unsettled the region
as china has grown more powerful calls
for the purchase of offensive weapons
are getting louder in japan
whether it's china or another nation
every country that knows we possess
offensive weapons and can defend
ourselves will adapt its behavior
towards us
the horrors of hiroshima have shaped the
country's military policy for decades
pacifism is written into japan's
constitution
but japan's new prime minister fumio
kishida is willing to change that
he is close to the military and has
argued for japan's right to own
offensive weapons
he would try to sort of
draw inspiration from the german
change
in order to make the same argument that
well we are in a similar situation and
japan should also you know now change
its position and start to re-militarize
more seriously
in 2020 japan spent more than 45 billion
euros on its military
that's met with resistance from peace
activists
the trauma of the second world war still
weighs heavily on many
no more war ever again
all my life i fought for that message
but here as elsewhere in the world
russia's war is accelerating re-armament
dw chief political editor michaela kufna
is traveling with chancellor schultz in
japan and she first explained what japan
is doing to aid ukraine
well fumio kishida was adamant that he
perceived japan's duty to help ukraine
to help the ukrainian people they are
sending
goods they're not sending weapons
because they have constraints within
their own constitution and a german
chancellor coming here first is a clear
political symbol that he does not want
to go to china first
he's not going to the most important
economic partner he's going to the
partner of the g7 of those western
democratic values and that's what both
nations have also vowed to stand in for
um further afield also here in the
region they're also doing joint military
exercises so this is all very new ground
both for germany and for japan and they
are seeing what happens in ukraine as a
threat to democracy and freedom
rather than a regional conflict
we'll get back to you in a second
mikhaila but first let's have a listen
to part of what uh olaf shots said at
that press conference that you were at
my trip is a clear political signal that
germany and the european union will
continue and intensify their engagement
in the indo-pacific region
in view of the russian war of aggression
our common focus is currently on ukraine
germany and japan stand side by side in
defending the rules-based international
order in upholding the fundamental
principles of the un charter and in our
commitment to universal human rights
a very clear statement there from shots
mikayla why is it so remarkable that
chancellor schultz would make his first
trip to asia to japan
because really rather than going where a
lot of germany's economic recovery was
particularly after the pandemic which is
china with an auto industry several auto
companies highly reliant on that chinese
market uh he's decided to go to japan
instead and both sides you know we hear
those values and that sounds a bit lofty
in a sound bite but when you really
break it down
this translate all translates also into
huge business delegations talking to
each other here in tokyo as well and
really a call by the german chancellor
on german industry to diversify
which also means not to be reliant on
one country namely also china when it
comes to their supply chains so
it is really trying to make the
economies more independent so
something on a different field can't
happen again like has happened to the eu
and germany that they are energy reliant
reliant solely on one country which at
the moment of course is russia
germany and japan both moved toward
pacifism after world war ii and berlin
that has begun to change since russia
invaded ukraine are we likely to see a
similar shift in tokyo
well it already was
quite a shift for japan to send goods in
fact the german chancellor will take
some supply goods not military but
humanitarian aid back in his own plane
so there's a lot of symbolism in that as
well there's a lot of solidarity and
germany also has is going on a very new
path what is seen as germany finally um
sending heavy weapons really is quite a
change quite a turnaround in itself
in terms of where germany puts its
support in hardware terms
so both countries are now seeing their
societies start this debate that could
potentially enable their leaders to go a
step further and one thing is for sure
everybody expects that conflict between
russia and ukraine and the pressure puts
on the international system the dear
strategic pressures to continue for a
very long time
uw's chief political editor mikhail
kufna in tokyo thank you so much